[Music]
[Applause]
the impossible challenge that's correct
going to 64 games every match at the
FIFA World Cup here in Qatar and so far
we've been successful
[Music]
with this idea when a FIFA partner
challenged me and said look we want to
send you to every single match but we're
only going to give you the tickets if
you attend every single one and I was
like look leave it in my hands I'm gonna
do this
foreign
kickoff and full time then I've attended
the game so if I make both games no
matter where they are then that's what
counts and I complete the challenge good
decision to leave Uruguay you'll never
Portugal Garner
the match was Neil nil at half time it
became 3-2 at the end of the match I had
to leave at half time to go to the
Brazil game at Lucile Stadium because
there's a second Stadium furthest away
so you missed a great game of the
challenge
why have they shot it
why did they shot the Morocco match
against Canada were they won 2-1
oh so we got to the stadium at half time
this might be the end of the challenge
no one could enter the stadium now
nobody nobody more they closed the
Stalls of showing no entry even if you
had a ticket they wouldn't allow you in
the stadium
and we were like what are we gonna do
here we're gonna have to call everyone
we possibly know everyone's getting
worried
and somehow we just found our way I'm
going to the school yeah
okay okay thank you
[Applause]
this is the best challenge I've ever
been put forward if someone offers you
to go to every single match at a World
Cup not only do I love football but I
also want to put a smile on people's
faces all across the world
[Applause]